SYCOPHANT.
JIMMY KIMMEL.
IF YOU WANT TO START WORLD WAR
II I AM READY.
FIRST JOE BIDEN PROJECTING
WEBNESS ON THE WORLD STAGE.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
-- WEAKNESS.
YOU HAVE AN ALLIANCE WITH IRAN,
RUSSIA AND CHINA RAMPING UP
THEIR MALIGNANT ACTIVITIES.
ON FRIDAY THE LARGEST OIL
PIPELINE NETWORK IN THE U.S. WAS
SHUT DOWN BECAUSE OF A CYBER
ATTACK.
THIS TRANSPORTS 50% OF ALL GAS
CONSUMED ON THE EAST COAST OF
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S INCLUDING FUEL USED AT
OUR MILITARY BASES.
THIS WAS A MAJOR ATTACK.
NOT ONLY GAS PRICES ALREADY SKY
ROCKETING.
THEY WILL GO HIGHER.
GAS STATIONS ARE STARTING TO RUN
OUT OF FUEL.
OUR MILITARY WAS IMPACTED.
THE PRESSING QUESTION:
JOE, HOW WILL YOU RESPOND?
MY GUESS IS THEY WILL DO
NOTHING.
CALL HUNTER.
HE GOT THE 3.5-MILLION DOLLARS
DEAL WITH THE FIRST LADY OF
MOSCOW.
THE WIRED MONEY FROM THE RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH.
AND JOE BIDEN IS DOING VERY
LITTLE.
WE HAVE CHINA'S MILITARY.
THEIR EXPANSION INTO THE PACIFIC
AND THE ARCTIC AS CHINA IS
THREATENING AUSTRALIA WITH
A LONG RANGE MISSILE STRIKE.
IN FEBRUARY JOE REWARDED BY IRAN
BY ENDING U.N. SANCTIONS PUT
INTO EFFECT BY DONALD TRUMP.
IRAN IS THE NUMBER 1 STATE
SPONSOR OF TERRORISM.
THE HOSTILE REGIMES CONTINUE TO
FUND PROXY WARS ACROSS THE
REGION.
A FEW DAYS AGO THE U.S. NAVY
INTERCEPTED THE SHIP FROM IRAN
TO YEMEN.
IT WAS CARRYING MISSILES, SNIPER
RIFLES AND OTHER CHINESE AND
RUSSIAN MADE WEAPONS BOUND FOR
ON THE PROXY WAR IN YEMEN
AGAINST THE SAUDIs.
THAT'S RUSSIA, CHINA AND IRAN
FIGHTING A PROXY WAR AGAINST
A GROUP WE ARE ALIGNED WITH, THE
JORDANIANS AND ISRAEL AND THE
SAUDIS.
IRAN LAUNCHED A ROCKET ATTACK ON
JERUSALEM.
ISRAEL RESPONDED WITH FORCE AND
ATTACKED GAZA.
THE ISRAELI EMBASSY IN THE U.S.
TWEETED IMAGINE IF A TERRORIST
GROUP WAS FIRING ROCKETS AT
WASHINGTON, D.C. OR LONDON.
IMAGINE THE PEOPLE OF PARIS
RUNNING INTO BOMB SHELTERS.
ISRAEL WILL DEFEND ITSELF.
JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO DECIDE:
WELL YOU GOING TO DEFEND ISRAEL?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO IMAGINE WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN ISRAEL.
WE HAVE BEEN ON THE GROUND IF
ISRAEL.
WE HAVE BEEN THERE DURING ROCKET
ATTACKS -- WE SHOWED YOU THE
PLAYGROUND KIDS PLAY WITH.
INDOOR IN A BUNKER IN A SMALL
ISRAELI BORDER TOWN BECAUSE IN
10 YEARS THEY HAD 10,000 ROCKET
ATTACKS AND IT WAS TOO DANGEROUS
FOR THE KIDS TO PLAY OUTSIDE.
THEY PLAY UNDERGROUND.
WE SHOWED YOU THE TUNNELS
CONSTRUCTED BY HAMAS USED LIE
TERRORISTS TO BYPASS BORDER
SECURITY AND CARRY OUT ATTACKS
IN ISRAEL.
THESE TUNNELS WERE CONSTRUCTED
WITH AMERICAN AND ISRAELI
FUNDING.
AND CONCRETE AND ELECTRICITY
MEANT FOR HOSPITALS AND SCHOOLS
AND REAL INFRASTRUCTURE, NOT JOE
BIDEN'S INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS IS WHERE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HALTED MILLION
DOLLARS IN AID TO PALESTINE.
THE MONEY JOE BIDEN PLEDGED OVER
200 MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
THAT FUNDS THE TERROR GROUP
HAMAS WHICH RULES PALESTINE WITH
AN IRON FIST.
BIDEN REINSTATED THAT AID.
NOW THAT THEY HAVE THE EXTRA
MONEY, THE ROCKET ATTACKS ARE
BACK AGAIN.
IT DID NOT HAVE TO BE THIS WAY.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A GREATER
ALLY FOR THE STATE OF ISRAEL
THAN DONALD TRUMP.
NOT ONLY DID HE MOVE THE U.S.
EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM, BUT HIS
SANCTIONS ON AMERICA'S ENEMIES
RESTORED ORDER TO THE MIDDLE
EAST AND AN ALLIANCE NOBODY
THOUGHT PROBLEM.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT THE
PEACE DEALS BROKERED BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BETWEEN
ISRAEL AND MULTIPLE ARAB STATES.
SOME REPUBLICANS HATED TRUMP SO
MUCH THEY WERE WILLING TO RISK
ALL OF THIS TO GET HIM OUT OF
OFFICE.
ONE IS LIZ CHENEY.
SHE HELPED JOE BIDEN GET ELECTED
AND SHE HAS HER OWN AGENDA.
LIZ IS OUT FOR LIZ.
HAVE AT IT.
SHE IS WILLING TO HELP THE
RADICAL SOCIALIST LEFT IF THAT
MEANS HATING ALL THINGS DONALD
TRUMP.
SHE IS OUT OF TOUCH WITH THE
BASE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND
HER LECTURING AND DIVISIVENESS
NOT HELPING THE GOP.
HAVING HER OWN AGENDA OVER THAT
OF THE PART, THAT CAN'T MOVE THE
COUNTRY FORWARD.
DON'T LISTEN TO THE NOISE IN THE
MEDIA, THEY DON'T LIKE LIZ
CHENEY EITHER.
WITH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
FOREIGN POLICY IN EFFECT, LIZ,
ARE YOU HAPPY?
DO YOU FEEL THE WORLD IS SAFER?
IT'S TIME FOR REPUBLICANS TO DO
WHAT THEY CAN TO OPPOSE THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THESE DANGEROUS POLICIES ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
BREAKING NEWS, NORTH CAROLINA
GOVERNOR ROY COOPER DECLARED
A STATE OF EMERGENCY OVER THE
TEMPORARY OUTAGE OF THE COLONIAL
PIPELINE CAUSE